From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Okay, we're going.
Today is Tuesday, May 31, 2011.
My name is Joe Mosnier of the Southern oral history program at University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I'm with filmmaker John Bishop in Selma, Alabama, where we are recording the oral history interview for the Civil Rights History Project,
which is an undertaking of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture,
where especially happy to be here today with you Miss Avery, we're in Selma as I mentioned with Miss Annie Pearl Avery to talk about your life and work and engagement with SNCC and all your efforts in the struggle.
Thank you for welcoming us to Selma and we're really pleased to be with you.
Thank you.
Thank you. I'm pleased to meet you.
Let me start this morning just to have you talk a little bit about where you were born and where you came up a little bit about your family.
Well, I was born in Birmingham, Alabama,
and my mother and father were wheeled and headed townships.
I was a first baby and my father was 54 years old when I was born. I was a first baby.
But anyway, we were, I say we were, we were a poem. I'm poor now, but we were pulled in.
But anyway, as time went on, in Birmingham, I had this situation where my aunt by the name had it and had it up in a Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania had a,
she and her husband didn't have any children, the husband deceased, and she wanted somebody to come stay with her.
And my mother had four of us, so my mother decided to share me with her for a few years.
That was your great aunt. That was my great aunt. That was my mother's aunt, which had been my great aunt.
And during that time I was in Pittsburgh. I went to Gladstone Elementary, lived in Hazelwood.
I lived on Sylvan Avenue. I think it was Sylvan Road, Sylvan Avenue. Sylvan Avenue, I'm sure I'm dead.
But anyway, during that time, Emmett Till was murdered. And I guess you can say for a child, I was only about nine or ten years old when he was murdered.
But the adults were in, you know, talking about it in the community and talking about it at my, at my home there, because my aunt had, had, had borders.
And they were talking about it and the way they were talking about it, they were just talking about a child.
The only thing I could understand, get out of it, was the child had been murdered.
A Negro child. And I, that's, I think that's what kind of peaked my interest.
Although I didn't understand lynching anything, but I did understand that a child was murdered and I was a child.
And I was curious about this, the child being murdered. And I looked for a newspaper around the house, usually the newspaper would be there, because she had a board of, they bring newspaper.
But I was head for the comics. And there was no newspaper that day. So I decided to go down to the, a little neighborhood grocery store where they had a, had a newspaper rack.
And I wanted to take a look at the paper. And I was from them with the paper and the, the, the store attendant told me I couldn't handle the paper unless I paid for it.
But fortunately by me being the only child member in the family, period cousins and I had some, the cousins there, but they were adults.
They spoiled me. They made sure I had pocket money to go to the movie. They made sure I had money to buy cookies and candy, bubblegum, whatever I wanted to do.
So I paid for the paper. And when I see it now in a humorous type of way, I said, well, I sacrifice a nickel. And I can't remember which paper it was, whether it was the Pittsburgh, the regular paper, every day paper there would have, I'm not sure whether the Pittsburgh, Korea, Pittsburgh, Kuzat or something like that.
It could have been, I'm not sure. But anyway, I tried to read this paper to try to understand the death of Emmett Till. But I still couldn't understand it really because I'm trying to understand it from a 9-10 year old point of view.
The only thing I understood that it was a child murdered and it was a black child murdered. Later on, I'm back in Birmingham. And a man was murdered by the name of Mack Charles Parker, Poplarville, Mississippi.
But I'm 14 years old now. And what happened is they had arrested him. Basically, the same type of thing that Emmett Till was murdered for making insult and remarks to a white female or something like that.
And they arrested him, kept him in jail for a couple of weeks. And there were threats to take him out of jail. And I was keeping up with that too. And then, all of a sudden, they went in and took him out of jail and killed him.
And right after that, there are a lot of other things begin to happen. The bus boycott in Montgomery, Autherine Lucy trying to enter the university, Ole Miss.
Reverend Shuttlesworth, right there in Birmingham, along with Reverend Charles Billups and Reverend Oliver and Reverend (J.L.) Phifer. These are the ministers that I remember that we're trying to desegregate the schools there in Birmingham.
Matter of fact, specifically, I think he was trying to desegregate Phillips High School, which my children graduated, both of my boys graduated from. But anyway, these things went on. And then after that came the cityans and the freedom rise. And I was really excited at that point, but I'm 16 years old now. So I understand this from a different level.
And on the news, I was hearing about young people being involved and young people were in the change. And I was young and I wanted to get involved.
So what I did is, I said, I wanted to go with them. I wanted to get involved. I wanted to go with them. And I didn't know whether they were going to come to Birmingham or what.
You mean freedom rise?
I'm speaking of the freedom rise. And when they got to, in Atlanta, I think, and they said they were coming to Birmingham, then I purchased a ticket from Birmingham to Montgomery.
And not long after I purchased a ticket, and I remember the bus arriving, about the bus arriving in Anniston, Alabama, and was blown up in Anniston, Alabama.
And then they came on to Birmingham. But you know, during that time they had two bus stations. They had Trailways and they had greyhound.
And Trailways was one that I was not that familiar with. I was more familiar with the greyhound bus station.
And I found out later on, why I was, I thought about later on, why I was in really more attracted to the greyhound bus station. My grandfather, my dad is father.
When he got older, he couldn't go anywhere by himself because he'd get lost. What some of us had to be with him. He was always going to the greyhound bus station.
But anyway, this is where I, you know, I kind of wanted to be. So I went that ticket and everything.
So when they got to Birmingham, and I went down to the greyhound bus station, along with a young lady at that time, that lived in the projects when I was a little girl.
Her name was Candace Grindes. Candace. Now Candace told me that her uncle was Reverend Abernathy.
But I didn't know this. You know, who Reverend Abernathy was. It was really running that important. To me, Abernathy, okay.
But we had decided to go down to the greyhound bus station to take a look. But what happened is it was roped off.
Then I wanted to go. I went down there. I think the next night after, and I talked. I met a guy by the name of Wilson Brown.
And Wilson, I think, was some kind of a part of a welcoming committee or something named Birmingham. I'm for the freedom writers when they got in.
And I told him I wanted to go. And Wilson said, okay, he started talking to me about nonviolence. I didn't understand nonviolence.
But when I bought the ticket, I had bought me a knife to go with the ticket, because I'm going to protect myself on the bus.
And Wilson told me I couldn't go because I didn't understand the concept of nonviolence. And I asked him what the nonviolence means.
He said, this is when someone hit you, you can't hit them back. I said, I don't think I want to do that. So I got a refund for my ticket.
And later on, I was seeing Wilson every night or every other night coming into the, the, uh, A.G. Gaston that lounge, which was a special spot for my, uh, my friends and myself, my other girlfriends and myself.
And, um, one night Wilson asked me not long after that, the, the, that I want to go to a student nonviolent coordinate committee meeting in Atlanta.
Well, the thought was I said, well, I never been to Atlanta before. And now I'm going to get a chance to go free.
Plus I want to learn more about what was going on in the civil rights movement. And I told him, yes, I left my knife at home.
And everything is history after that.
That was your first big move towards direct involvement?
Yeah, that was the first, first big movement towards getting involved in the move and in the civil rights movement.
I came to the meeting before we tell the Atlanta story. I want to ask a couple of things.
Um, I have a note from the research that I did in preparing for the session that in the late 50s, you've become quite interested and considered joining and perhaps, um, did become a member of the nation of Islam.
Well, what happened is, um, I made my first, um, contact with people in the nation of Islam when Mack Charles Parker was in jail before he was murdered.
And they were the only had the Muhammad Speaks. And this was the only paper that had the head something meaningful about this man every day in the paper, even up till the time he was murdered and even after he was murdered.
And this is what attracted me to them because this was something visible that I had seen so going on.
Well, I saw something going on, I should say.
And I started going to some of the meetings and the thing about this was that, um, they weren't visible enough for me.
Maybe it just wasn't enough activity, which, um, I'm not saying that what they were doing wasn't important.
But it just, it just wasn't enough activity going on around it for me.
I guess I wanted more action and I saw more direct action with, um, the civil, the, the sit and the Freedom Rides, although I know core was a part, more part of some of the Freedom Rides itself.
But the thing about this is they, they just, so, so I went with what, what was more, more active, visibly active.
Then, um, can I ask you, I'm just before you're about to head for that sneak meeting at Atlanta.
What was your life like in Birmingham? What can you describe the community, the, the things that, um, were taking up your time, the, what you were witnessing in the community?
Well, I was riding the back of the bus and I don't know maybe, maybe this thing of living in Pittsburgh, um, and living under different conditions might have made, made the difference because, um, when I went to Pittsburgh and we got to, um, Cincinnati, I think.
And my aunt told me I could sit anywhere I wanted to sit.
But I still, they still didn't don't know me because you have to remember I'm only nine or ten years old and sitting in the way I wanted to sit.
It really didn't, although in Birmingham, when I got on the bus, I saw the science in color.
But it still wasn't, you know, didn't, wasn't as meaningful. But then once I got to Pittsburgh and associating with the other children, it's really who I learned a lot of stuff because they were saying, don't say yes, sir.
And no, sir is yes and no. And they would tell me about how to, I'd go to the store to ask for a drink, orange drink. And they said, don't ask for a drink. You asked for a pop.
And I just found out just about four weeks ago, why they calling a pop, you know, what started them calling these things a pop.
But anyway, I, um, I changed a lot there. And I guess the coming back to Birmingham and then going back to riding the back of the bus, and I went to integrated school now.
In Pittsburgh. And it was different. One perfect, but it was different. And, um, this, I guess this is what motivated me to probably get involved.
What do you think about some of the trips to Atlanta?
Well, the trip to Atlanta, when I got to Atlanta, um, and I met people, met, met people there, um, that eventually, um, I became friends with and affected my whole life.
And actually in terms of the idea of meeting some decent white people, because I'd never met any decent white people to know them until I got to that meeting.
And in Anne Braden (likely), I met, uh, Bob Zellner, I met Dottie Miller Zellner, who became a dottie Zellner later on. I met Penny Patch, I met Bill Hansen, and there was a lot of other people I met.
And, um, and even the blacks that I met, I met Ms. Ella Baker, I met James Forman, I met Ruby Doris Smith, um, I met Julian Bond, I met so many, so many people, um, that I hadn't, had never met before.
And I, I guess you can say I went into it, uh, from a learning, from a learning stage.
Uh, I never knew anything I did was going to be important.
So that was an annual meeting last of what a couple of days?
Uh, this one, I think for a, a couple of days of weekend or something like that, because at that time, SNCC had their first, their first office was on Auburn Avenue upstairs over the Atlanta Daily World, where the Atlanta Daily World was on Auburn Avenue.
Uh, and it had holes in the floor. You know, we had to be careful, but we went upstairs, but we had to be careful about where we walked, you know, because the big hole in the floor they were doing constructions, something on the bill.
Yeah, and then we went, it went from there to Raymond Street, but, um, anyway, after that Atlanta meeting, um, matter of fact, on the way back home, we got in trouble.
And almost got murdered right there in Marietta, Georgia.
Well, what we did is we got confused trying to get back to Birmingham, Wilson Brown, Nathaniel Lee, and there was a white girl that wanted to meet Reverend Shuttlesworth.
No, I never, no, no, because I never saw her again. She wanted to meet Reverend Shuttlesworth and myself. That's what we, we, we were all in the car together.
And she had been at the SNCC meeting too.
And we got confused and ended up in Marietta, Georgia.
And we said, well, let's go in the bus station and get some inspiration.
What we went into bus station, and now we in trouble, because we go into bus station, and these people see this white girl with us.
And during that time, if you were in a mixed group together, you were considered part of the civil rights movement.
Which I didn't know at the time, it hadn't really thought about it at that point.
But this is what the situation was when we left the bus station, the police followed us.
And when the police were, we still don't know where we're going. And we couldn't find any black people.
Just ask, we didn't see any black people. And we got stopped.
We hadn't done anything, but we got stopped. Police pulled us over.
And by being Marietta, Georgia, I'm saying it was just like, you go two blocks and you're out of the sit limits.
And all you headed out of the other area there, and what happened is the police stopped us.
Arrested Wilson, commented the car.
And now, we don't have no way to get around. And Wilson's in jail.
And we've standing out on the street trying to figure out what to do.
Try to find a black community, no black folk.
And I said, let's go back to the bus station.
Because we can still see the bus station right there. Once we got back into the sit, they made Wilson drive his car with us in it.
Put us out. Take Wilson to jail. Take the car.
And there we are. And we decided to go to the bus station finally.
And we got to the bus station. The attendant told us we couldn't stay.
Because we weren't customers.
I said, I thought about it. I said, just by tickets.
Back to it. We couldn't back tickets too far. Back to Atlanta.
Anything. But this made us, because I understood the part about the, what was it?
In a state chamber, commerce, the law is, they had to, you know, once we became customers,
since they said we weren't customers, okay, we'll become customers.
And you still were traveling freely?
Yeah. And that way they couldn't kick us out of the bus station.
And we stayed in the bus station there. And what we did is right after that, we called back to the SNCC office
and talked to someone there.
I think, you know, I don't know who we talked to now. I forgot now.
But anyway, we talked to someone. But during that time, if you remember, they had switchboards.
You couldn't dial directly out, you had a switchboard. And we were using the payphones in the bus station.
And finally, but this was a way to communicate at least let folks know where we were.
And by this time, it's about dark. Dark, just got dark. And it was really, really frightening.
It wasn't too frightening at first. It was kind of like kind of odd, but not too frightening.
Until it got darker and we got crowd, crowd, people crowded. But only white people.
More and more people, that bus station probably had had that many people in it.
And the people in it, in the history of the Marietta, Georgia. But it had a lot of people at night.
And one white girl. And we started getting phone call.
When we first said figure out where we were going to take a refuge, we didn't know where it was.
Three phone booths there. We decided we were going to take a phone booth in peace if things got worse.
Well during that time, they had phone booths. You know, when you used the phone, they had a booth.
The door was closed on it.
So you were thinking each to get inside a walk-on and close the door?
Yeah, we got three, three, three booths. You all got a booths.
This was going to be our refuge. But in the meantime, we were getting called.
We're back on after short break. I mean the sun was.
So you were just getting in.
Miss Avery, you were just...
Well, I was just getting into the part about the switchboard.
You know, they had switchboards in.
Yes.
And in order to get a call out, you had to go through a switchboard.
And not long after we made the call, obviously they must have called a Associated Press.
'Cause at that time, I think Julian was... Julian Bond was on the staff of Atlanta.
Inquirer. Is it Atlanta inquirer?
Anyway, he was on the staff of some of the small black newspaper.
And what he did, what they did was...
The Associated Press started calling us.
Asked...
On the pay phone.
They started calling us asking us where we are okay.
Every few minutes they called back and asked where we are okay.
But the thing about this is...
I don't think nobody could have gotten to us.
I think if we had stayed there longer than we did, just so happened.
We were there until probably about 12 o'clock that night.
But the later it got the worst these people got.
And more hostile they became.
They got sticks and started beating on the seats.
And shouting all kind of synergies and threats.
They were going to kill us.
And calling the white girl a nigger level.
This kind of stuff.
And we're going to kill y'all niggas tonight.
And the later it got, the more frightening it got.
And finally, Julian Bond and some other people showed up.
I think Howard Moore...
He was one of the slick lawyers.
And he finally married Julian, sister Jane.
But James Forman, Julian, Howard Moore, and a few other people came along.
I think with some people from the Justice Department to get Wilson out of jail
and get us out of there and form it decided we shouldn't try to go to Birmingham
that night, stay in Atlanta and then go to Birmingham during the day.
How did they do with the crowd when they got there?
How did they find their way in to get you and extract you from being surrounded by that crowd?
Well, we don't really know, except they came in and told us we can, you know, let's go.
You know, after they got Wilson out of jail, they came to work.
Because the town is, these jailers on the corner, Graham bus station probably,
you know, when I can visualize it now, just probably across the street.
Because we can see the Graham bus station from the jailhouse on the corner.
And it wasn't that far.
Did they come back with any vocal sheriffs from police officers?
No.
No, never happened.
So they just on their own authority.
Well, the people who came came from Atlanta.
They didn't come from Marietta.
These were people who came in from Atlanta.
And I think it was part of the Justice Department, a member of something from the Justice Department.
But they had somebody from the Justice Department.
I think so.
They had a black car, they had black cars, they had government cars, they had all of black.
But I'm assuming it was, anyway, somebody from the Justice Department came there to assist us.
That person, why the Justice Department?
I think so.
It's a lot of stuff.
It's kind of vague in it except for the party in the bus station.
Tell me about the impact on you was at being in such a very fearful situation.
Well, I knew that it was very, very good chances of getting really hurt or keeled.
But on the other hand, I learned to keep become and use my head when I'm in a situation.
And that's in any situation.
I applied it today because going to that bus station was the best thing we could do instead of trying to look for a black community.
We don't know where the black community is.
We didn't see any black people.
The bus station we could see that.
Then when they told us we couldn't stay and we had, you know, when it came to me quick to get the tickets.
Let's get the tickets.
We got the tickets.
We weren't out of harm's way.
But we were in a situation and out of rubber being there and out on the road somewhere, when it got dark.
It's a good thing they did stop us before it got dark.
You see, because stopping us out on the road with no communication, nobody around at all, even if they were bad people.
It's better to have some people around.
But anyway, it was just something that I learned learned early on in terms of some of the things that I did later on that probably saved my life.
Now, when we finally got the Birmingham, we met Reverend Shuttlesworth.
And this was my first time meeting Reverend Shuttlesworth.
Right?
And he heard about what had happened in America?
No. Wilson called him and told him he had somebody to watch the meeting.
And we went to his place and he was still in his pajamas when we met him.
And this was my first time meeting him, being right there in Birmingham, but all this activity going on.
This was the very first time I met Reverend Shuttlesworth.
And not long thereafter, I think you participated in the sit in the war?
You participated in a sit at the war?
Yeah.
He had me down at the World War II because we were going to test the sit ends there.
And we went to, I think it was the war worth, the creases, or one of the places, I think it was World War.
And from when we went in there and Wilson and Reverend Shuttlesworth and Reverend Charles Billups were standing on the side.
And the group of, I guess this was a, I think this was the very first sit in that Birmingham had.
And we were going to test the sit end.
Well they didn't, so they didn't arrest us, but they didn't serve us.
But what happened is they had a white fellow that was going down the counter, spitting, and pulling ketchup.
And I hadn't quite been adjusted to this nonviolent thing.
I wasn't sure how I was going to react to this spitting and being, you know, pulling ketchup and Reverend Shuttlesworth.
Somehow I was active and I was, you know, and he said, come here.
I want you to stand here beside me because I hadn't really learned much about the nonviolence thing to really want to use it as a tactic or anything.
I hadn't learned enough about it to accept it for any reason.
But I wanted to go sit on the lunch counter.
And I told Reverend Shuttles, I want to go back up there. He said, you can't go.
He didn't stand right here with me.
But anyway, later on, I went to, I think of an Albany, Georgia.
I don't know what that went there then or either had, anyway, I got arrested in Albany, Georgia.
And I think we had an attorney named by the name was CB King.
And there were some other people I met. The first people I met were Ruth, I met Rutha Mae Harris.
I met, I think, Bernice Johnson Reagon.
And I met Charles Sherrod.
I think, yeah, I had already met him up in the, and I met Bob Mants.
Bob Mants. And, Rev. Prathia Hall.
And I'm trying to thank some of the people that I met.
Can you tell me a little bit about your impression of these people, these other folks like yourself,
who are making up, snickering these days, and what they were like and what you liked about them,
what you didn't like about them, what attracted you to them?
Well, what attracted me was, is mostly just, you know, I've met these people,
and they were already involved. So I was like, in a learning stage,
I thought I considered myself being in a learning stage at all the time,
it was something I could learn from them, and, or, participate.
But mostly it was an educational thing for me, because some of these people even had higher education,
and education in Adi, but I was getting educated too, just being there with them,
and just talking with them, and exchanging ideas, just asking them,
I said very little during that time.
Did you feel, when you were getting involved in the process directly,
did you feel, I wonder how, what, what the emotional experience of going through a protest
with a lot of hostility around you, was like for you?
Did you feel a lot of anger, did you feel a lot of fear, did you feel calm?
What was the mix of emotions for you in a situation like that?
Well, the thing about anger, I had been in this environment so long,
I've seen, you know, I didn't walk around being angry all the time.
It might have been emotional, even just one to achieve something and do,
and one thing should be better, basically, because I guess because I had been exposed to a different situation,
you know, they say, slave, and it's slave, no, be slave, no more.
If you've been free, you don't want to be slave anymore, so I guess that psychologically
that might have, in my subconscious probably had a lot to do with it.
I can't say which one thing, or a combination of things,
I really can't, can't say, except I can just probably pinpoint some things
and say that this probably was what happened.
And I'm just realizing that in the last few months, a few years,
that these are the kind of things that probably brought me to do with idea.
When you were down to Albany, was your status, what was your status for SNCC,
were you a volunteer or were you getting paid?
No, I was a volunteer. I don't think anybody was getting paid at that time.
But they finally, somehow another, because this thing, but it's probably too good to be true.
I guess the government, everybody else thinks this was a way to also disqualify SNCC,
and the younger groups, because where can you get people who want to go to jail,
take a risk on their life, and don't get paid.
We were going to people's houses, staying with them, and helping do the housework,
and stuff like this, and then do voter registration too, and do the demonstrations
or whatever was going on that support the community.
So it's kind of strange that they asked, I think we were getting,
they finally forced them into giving us $10 a week, I think it was.
Which is still nothing, but it was just a way to probably make us use our funds.
What are some of the things that come first in mind when you think about going down to Albany that first time,
Charles Sherrod and the other folks are down there, and they put the Albany moving together?
Well, I wanted to find out what Georgia, I think they were, I think,
Bob Mantz was in America, as I believe.
But what happened is, I was just there to assist in whatever they wanted me to do.
Pretty much, that's basically what I did during that time.
Tell me more or tell, how you spent your time?
What was it like to go out to do voter registration?
Well, I did, I think I tried to do voter registration one day, and the next day I went on the demonstration,
and I got locked up, and I was in there for, I don't know, it was quite some time, I was about three or four weeks, I guess.
Tell me about, if you do it, what was it like to do in the jail?
What's the whole experience like to be in jail at that time in that kind of place?
Well, I was in there for something good and important, I thought.
But what happened is, I really, just in order to adapt to this situation, I just really kind of put it in the back of my mind,
and I was going on outside and tried to adapt to the environment around me, I was able to get some,
some packages of cigarettes and stuff like this, anything that I could read or something,
that's how I adjusted, I just immediately adapted, and I guess that's probably one of the things that I've been good at,
is adapting to my environment, at all times, with an NGO or out of jail, I adapt to my environment.
I'm going to ask about the episode, experience you had when after William Moore,
was a white postal fairy, actually, through the march and was killing their Gadsden.
Guests in Alabama?
Yeah.
And there was someone certain to be about what, not Smith, was how they would respond,
and you had a choice about how they respond to you.
Did you talk about that?
Yeah, well, they had decided on what they were going to do, and my position was to go,
do what William Moore was doing, to finish what he started, even if I had to finish it alone.
And I didn't realize when I decided to make a decision to do this,
that I was really actually taking on the march the way he did it alone.
I just didn't realize it, I just figured that we needed to go ahead and march.
And my intention was to go with other people, but I didn't know how long it was going to be before,
either weather level was going to go at all because it was so much, it was a dilemma,
and so much discussion about it.
And I made a decision to get me a sign and go on the way you're more of march.
I was arrested a few minutes later after I started walking with the sign,
and I was placed in jail in Gaston, Alabama, where the next day or two some other people were arrested.
And the females, I had no other arrested, were Diane Nash,
I believe it or not, Madeleine Sherwood, who was one of the movie stars,
she came down and she was arrested in the William of March.
She played in what if the Cat on a Hot Tin Roof, she played the pregnant woman on the hot tin roof,
and she came down and she bundled it out right away.
She was on a white female in the group, I think, and she was bonded out right away,
but Diane and two other young ladies from Birmingham were locked up,
and they put them in a cell, I think, next to me.
But before that, they were trying to interrogate me and try to find out how I got there,
and they told me, I didn't give them any information, I told them,
I just might, take me on into the cell and put me in the jail,
or do whatever y'all gonna do, because I ain't talking.
I never did tell them how I got there, who brought them?
Or what the details, no details at all.
And later on, we were moved to, with Tutwiler,
and then they were like, they were in there for about ten weeks,
we were in there quite a while together, for that I can't be exact.
But they moved us to with Tutwiler, because it was supposedly a threat to come in the jail and take us out,
and took, and do what's in.
And so the young men who barred, they took them to Kilby, and took us to with Tutwiler,
and when we got to with Tutwiler, they put us in a hole,
the first night we stayed in a hole, then they put us in the hospital,
with the people in the hospital, although we were sick,
but I guess they decided that this is the best place for us to be,
so we would stir up any trouble in jail.
So they put you in the hole?
It was a hole, we had to crawl.
It was a seal, it was dark, and it was a hole like,
because we really couldn't stand up in there, it was dark.
I don't think I remember it was dark in there,
and we could maneuver around, I guess they had us in there for,
in that particular area for a reason, that night.
But then the next morning, when they moved us to the hospital part of jail,
and one of the women who were bringing around the trays,
it was a trustee, she was bringing the trays for the sick people in the hospital,
and she asked us, she said, where are y'all from?
We knew the freedom fighters were here,
and they didn't want us to know, but we knew about it, everybody knows.
That's what the lady said, she said, everybody knows.
So she asked us, where were we from?
She asked Diane, Diane said, Nashville,
the other two girls said, Birmingham, I said Birmingham,
and I asked her, wherever she from, she said, Tuscaloosa,
and she said she was in there for life.
Some guy she was with.
You mentioned that, you mentioned a moment ago that,
after more was killed,
that there was a lot of discussion as to what to do,
and they decided to go forward more.
You mentioned earlier too that,
when your first encounter, these are about nonviolence of a strategy,
and the movement, you know, had some skepticism about that in some way.
Can you explain a little bit about how your perspective,
how your opinions and viewpoints compared to the ones that you saw in SNCC in these years?
Did you feel sometimes that there was some difference between your instincts
about how to do things and what SNCC was doing?
Well, I can only speak to individuals,
because there were certain individuals who took this on as a way of life.
I was just one of those people among others who did not adopt nonviolence as a way of life,
only as a tactic.
Okay, we're back after short break.
Miss Avery, we'll build the story towards all the way up to room beyond Selma,
but I want to ask now, 60, say, 62, 63.
You haven't, you went into a number of different places for SNCC.
Yeah. Can you skimps that out and talk about what you did and what you saw and how you felt?
And what those were very busy, busy years for SNCC, and you were right in the middle of that?
Well, what happened is I was then Birmingham too,
had been one of the first, one of our first demonstration, and was arrested.
And then we were told that the decoy march, because what we did is,
Wyatt Tee Walker had me to go on the decoy march,
and it was only about 10 or 15 people,
and this was the throw, throw the police off,
because what they were doing is, if you marched,
you didn't have more marches.
But a little bit of they know that the bigger march was coming later.
And one of my best friends, I was talking to her, I said, you're going, I said, yes, I'm going.
And she said, I ain't going.
But on the second march, she came along, and I guess she did,
because there was so many other people,
who she was all the one going to be left out,
because they arrested the other people and myself,
and then later on, they showed up.
And I said, what you're doing here, better?
She said, I said, but you said you didn't want to go, you wasn't going.
She said, I wasn't going to be out there by myself.
So I guess when several other people,
who I was associated with friends,
had decided they were going to go,
and she just said, she wasn't going to be alone,
she's about to go to.
You were in Danville a while?
Yes, I was in Danville Virginia.
I was arrested several times in Danville,
but I was arrested there,
and put in solitary confinement ahead,
a 90-day sentence for contempt of court in Danville.
What was the judge's time to get back to work?
Well, we came to court.
Matthew Jones, who just passed recently,
and was one of the freedom singers.
Matthew, along with Avon Rollins, in Danville,
we were working in Danville together,
and I think it was some other guy there,
and came in from SCLC, and I can't think of what it meant.
I might think of it in a minute, but anyway,
we'd gone to court on some cases.
We had several cases already pending from jail.
When we got there,
and it was crowded inside the courthouse,
and out in the hall, Matthew and I just showed up,
and looked in there, looked down,
and the trial, the court case,
already started, and the judge was asleep.
Asleep! literally, sleep.
You're not in there.
I said, Matthew, see this?
He's asleep.
I said to Matthew, let's wake him up.
What we did is we went down to the front of the podium
where he was asleep and went limp.
Just laid down on the floor.
He woke up, and he asked the police officers
standing on the side.
He said, what's wrong with him?
The police officer said,
you're honored. That's what they call going limp.
He was mad. He gave us 90 days.
He wouldn't take it back,
so we had to serve our 90 days in solitaire from family.
When I got out of jail,
for that particular incident,
Ava and Rollins,
who was project director at the time,
told me to go on and take a break.
I go home to take a break.
I get in the Birmingham late Saturday evening,
and I go to bed,
and what awakened me the next morning
was the bombing of the 16th Street Baptist Church.
That's what awakened me.
I lived about 16 blocks
from there,
walked up to that time
on Sunday morning,
buses ran slow,
so I was able to walk
and wasn't there for it during that time.
16 blocks,
18 blocks, nothing to walk.
So I walked up to,
it's closest to the A.G. Gaston,
and motel,
and they had everything else roped off.
And soon after that,
Miss Ella Baker showed up.
Dr. King came in,
Reverend Abernathy.
there was Jim Forman,
Andrew Young,
and this was the first time I met Larry Steele,
who was an editor of Jett at the time,
and things were emotional
because of the children being murdered.
Later on that night,
we were in a room standing,
sitting down and talking,
and this is where we were in that room,
talking about things to do,
and we were pretty upset.
We didn't which way to go.
We weren't sure about just,
we weren't planning to do anything violent,
but we wanted to take some kind of direct action
that was more aggressive than just marching
and going to jail at that time.
Then I was in,
where was it?
Let me ask,
boy, think about that.
Let me ask the two other places,
if you work in Hale County.
Yeah.
Can you work in that?
I will, Hale County,
a project director in Hale County,
on voter registration,
and that was before I came here,
but I was in Mississippi,
when the changes weren't in Goodman,
where murder I was in Clarksdale,
Mississippi,
and I went from Clarksdale to Natchez, Mississippi.
I was arrested in Natchez, Mississippi.
I came here to organize voter registration project,
and there were several other friends of mine
that came in,
Cynthia Washington, I think,
was up in Greene County.
Pitcher might have been in Perry County,
or Greene County.
I think it was,
Perry County, Greene County.
And then,
they walked back on the after-show break,
talking about project director work in Hale County.
Can you tell me what,
what project director was like,
all the things that you were required to do,
and how you went about that work?
Well, what we did is,
we first, when you first scored a community,
we tried to find a place to stay in the community,
we let the community people know who we are,
and why we're there,
and find a place to live.
Sometimes we found places to live,
sometimes we didn't,
because of the fear of people,
but we were able to rent a house there in Hale County.
And when we first went through the community,
we met some guy,
I don't know if a guy is in the,
he was a sergeant in the Army,
and he said,
he wasn't going,
he said, he didn't believe in everything we believed in,
and he said, he didn't believe in none violence.
So, we still ask him to come to the mass me,
but lo and behold,
the first mass me being in the head,
when the meeting was over,
he was standing outside with his army right now.
He said,
I just want to be sure everything was going to be alright.
It's okay.
And sometimes I know they said that we had,
but had guns,
but the thing is,
a lady by the name of Ms. Johnny May,
I forget her,
and Hale County said,
she said,
y'all have weapons.
We said no.
The two people were working during that time
with St. Clair,
Jetta, and myself.
And he was the one taught me how to drive.
So, it's something happening to him.
I can see a drive to car.
And anyway,
they gave us a shotgun,
a 10 gauge shotgun.
And so, every morning,
we got up.
St. Clair was teaching me how to use a shotgun,
because as far as I told him how to hunt,
and just across the road from us,
it was a dead end street with them,
just across the road from us.
There was a white family.
They had a big fence up around their house.
But the funny thing about it is,
us having that gun,
and him teaching me how to use it,
actually,
probably helped save us a lot of time,
because they probably said,
well, these people supposed to be known by them,
but they got a gun.
And that's what I call minor justice.
You know, he got a gun,
but they're not involved.
Yeah, but they got a gun.
You know, we went,
the registered people to vote,
we went to march at the Courthouse and stuff like that,
but these people got a gun.
And you know,
in my opinion,
the clan and all of these people
who did all these evil things,
were cowards.
So, a coward,
don't want to encounter nobody,
they're really can equal up to them.
So,
just a psychological effect,
that they got a gun.
And the only thing St. Clair was doing,
without the back door,
it was a big,
a long field of woods down in there.
And he just said,
showing me how to hold a shotgun,
and how to use it.
Did there ever come a time
where you picked up the gun
thinking you'd have to use it?
No.
We had some sort of the same situation
in that specific.
Chico Neblett was the project director there,
and we didn't have a place to stay.
We stayed in the ladies room.
She had a room,
that she was renting,
and she worked in a cafe at night,
and we slept there.
So, we didn't have anywhere to go.
People wouldn't look,
wouldn't give us a place to stay.
And slick ended up buying a house there.
I think the house was pretty cheap.
I think they got her about $3,000,
or something like that,
maybe less.
You know,
but we did have a place to stay there,
but I came here after
a natural Mississippi to work
with on a voter registration.
And then when Jimmie Lee Jackson
had been killed here,
there was a decision
to the original decision
was to take his dead body
to Selma in a casket,
and finally,
it boiled down to us just marching.
But now, the night before the march,
we got a call.
The reason Dr. King,
because Dr. King was supposed to be here,
but he was not here.
We got a call.
We were in a strategy meeting
and sitting around talking,
and the following call came in directly
from Attorney General,
and the General,
Katzenbach's office,
saying that Martin's life was in danger.
And we took Martin away from here that night,
and Hosea Williams and Andrew Young
flipped the call on who was going to represent
SCLC on the march.
That's how Hosea Williams got that spot.
That's the reason you see Hosea Williams
at the end in the parts.
And you'll see John Lewis
and you'll see (Amelia) Boynton
and Miss Marie Foster.
And Marie Foster was one of the people
who marched all the way on the last march.
The go back though,
I got arrested.
He owned blood as Sunday.
But I was the only person that got arrested.
See, the intent was to terrorize us
and brutalize us.
And strike fear,
and so much fear in us,
that we wouldn't want to march.
Now, with all the police that they had,
and what they had,
the police land was the traffic light,
the first traffic light you get to
after you go across the bridge,
it was just about right along in that area.
Let me just mention,
we turned the look over our shoulder
after the window.
And you said you were straight out the window,
you could see that red.
What happened is the head road blocked off.
And their intention was really to hurt us.
Now, before we marched,
myself and some other people came out
and drove around, took a look.
Just to see what the situation was like.
Scouting.
Scouting, yeah.
And we could see where the head had lined off.
Not only that,
the reason I got arrested
was the police and I was having a physical disagreement
about where I wanted to be
and where he wanted me to be.
'Cause after, I guess, the tear gas,
because I didn't get a fix to the tear gas.
I was arrested pretty, pretty quick,
when the police and I had this difference
and taken on off the jail.
But the intent was really to brutalize us
because if their intent was to stop us
and arrest us,
that was what they didn't arrest,
but me one.
But most of the stuff that went on was beatings
and tear gas and...
And they even took pictures of it themselves.
They took their own pictures of it.
If you go to the museum now
and you're seeing the bottom where it says
Alabama Department Department of Public Safety.
What we didn't have in the cameras anyway,
we couldn't afford the cameras.
Because I've had people ask me,
say, where is your picture?
I said, no, tell them where I was.
I said, we didn't take the pictures.
And plus, I wasn't trying to stop
on any demonstration I was on.
I was just probably going to be part of it.
See you March on 21st.
Seven.
I marched on the seven.
There were all three of them,
we had three marches.
And then on the nine.
Then on the nine.
And then on the final march.
But I didn't walk all the way to Montgomery.
What was your role?
Well, I was still...
Still, just project director.
I was just a little bit more of a role.
Of he, okay.
That's all I was.
You know, a lot of...
The often would ask you to help with security.
Like you mentioned going out scouting
and trying to get a sense of what might be waiting in terms of police response.
Is that a...
Or did you sometimes do some of that kind of work?
Not often, because I didn't drive.
I just learned to drive.
But I was sitting on certain...
I had certain things to do.
From time to time.
I was just chosen.
I...
Not maybe out of the clear blue,
because the people knew who they were choosing to do.
Because right there in Birmingham,
the State Patrol were looking for Dr. King to give him an injunction.
And I had just gotten out of jail in Birmingham.
And what they were trying to do is enjoying all the people who were marched.
Or either they thought were going to march like Dr. King.
And I'm sitting in the lounge there with my friend Betty and some other people.
But Dr. Wyatt (Tee) Walker, Dr. Wyatt (Tee) Walker,
chose me to do this.
But I think that I was chosen to do it because Betty couldn't have kept it quiet.
You know, in hindsight, that's probably what it was.
And he walked over to me and he whispered in my ear.
And he said,
go around to rooms such as...
I forgot what the room was now.
Go around there and tell them
that the police is out here looking for Dr. King.
Said, Dr. King, round there, and the room, round there.
He's round.
They had registered in the master suite,
but he didn't wouldn't stay in the master suite.
He was round in the room with Andy and Bernard Lee,
who was one of his lieutenants.
And I discreetly and quietly got up and walked out.
Told my friends I'd be back in a minute.
Walked out, went around, told them to come back and sit down.
That was part of the D-Core march and stuff like that.
And I did stuff like that for the time and the time.
Especially since we're right here looking at the window at the bridge.
What are the memories come most vividly to your mind
and think about those three marches on that bridge?
Uh, really Sunday.
You know, what happened is after the march was over
and I finally got out of jail, but you know something?
This was the shortest time I'd ever stayed in jail.
It was right here and so.
Atturning Peter Hall, barring the me out out of his pocket.
That's what happened.
He came in from Birmingham.
He was one of our attorneys.
He came in and somebody had been looking for me
and somebody told him that I was in jail.
And he came to the jail, barring me out,
got in his car, went back to Birmingham.
Matter of fact, he was back in Birmingham before I was released.
They didn't release me right away.
I don't know why they kept me then to 11, 12 o'clock at night
because the barch had been over and stuff like that.
And I had been bond out long before that.
But they didn't release me until then.
Maybe they thought I was going to get out there and join them again
as soon as they let me out or something.
I don't know.
I can only assume.
But I just stayed in jail a few hours.
And that was phenomenal compared to all of the times
that I've been in jail.
The longest time I've been in jail was in Danville, Virginia
and 90 days for Contemporary Court.
You think you're paying?
We're back after short break.
And one thing I know you wanted to share some thoughts about
was the election brothel.
Yes.
Well, being the first African American president,
I never thought it would happen during my time.
But if it did, always thought his name would be Charles, Joe,
John, Henry, Bob.
I never thought he would have an African name.
And that kind of excited me even more.
And I said to myself, this is my personal thought.
I said, it don't get no better than this.
And also that he was being elected on my 60-feet birthday.
And you know when your 60-feet birthday, that's a turning point
in your life.
And I said, oh boy, this is real good.
Yeah, I was really excited.
Not just about him being African American,
but because he has an African name, which was expected.
At first when he said, oh no, we're going to have a problem.
And I just, you know, it was just astounding just to think
that it happened.
I want to ask too.
I got a few more things to ask you.
One is, you were relatively young when you first went to that
at land meeting.
Yes.
No, I was 16.
Because you were only 16.
16?
You were on 43.
But I turned, I was 16, turned in 17 in November.
So when I got arrested, I was 17.
But very first meeting then would have been still in 1960.
Thanks for that.
Tell me the first meeting with SNCCP?
No, it would have been 61.
Yes, exactly.
Okay, I thought you said 61.
So you could still a very young person about 18, 17, 18.
And you were very quickly the moving whole time into a long, important roles for SNCCP.
And you were the project director.
I'm wondering about your feeling about your roles in the SNCCP and the roles of women in the SNCCP.
And how do you felt about how you were able to use your skills and your talents and your personality and all your efforts on behalf of SNCCP?
Well, I didn't think too much of it over time.
I was just being myself.
And I wasn't trying to start.
So I was just, but one thing I found out later on.
I didn't know who Harriet Tubman was, but I found out that I was a model and they Harriet Tubman when they come down to go in the jail.
And the people would get in jail.
And there was an experience of sometimes people, some people would maybe one individual would break down because the psychological effect of closing that iron door had an effect on you.
If you didn't know how to adapt to that and take it and turn it into something, what you call a suffering for doing, getting something better done or getting something done that was good.
But what happened is, when people would come in and when somebody started that, as a, hey, no, we can't have that.
But we have a problem in here.
We're in jail.
And what happened is, the people who are jailers and stuff will take advantage of this and try to do things to frighten us.
And this is one of the reasons you don't want to do this.
And then the other prisoners in jail will think that they can run over us.
So the best thing we can do if you feel like, you know, you want to cry, go in the closet, go in the, you know, you can call me and talk to me, don't, don't start that here.
And then nothing of one do it.
Three or four of us might do it and start demanding to get out of jail because they don't ask if we're going to get us some cards.
And then we'll get us some dominoes if we can.
And sometimes we were able to do this.
And sometimes we had money on us.
It wasn't much money, but remember now you're in jail.
And if you want to get cigarettes and you got 50 cents, you can get a pack of cigarettes.
Somebody'll get your pack of cigarettes.
You know, things that, you know, if we were in a situation where you were allowed, because a lot of times we weren't allowed to have anything.
Point blank, nothing.
But there were times when, you know, we were in jail.
And there would be, when they come around, they didn't discriminate on that.
They come around and say, well, who wants cigarettes?
Or if they wouldn't get us a book or anything like that, we could get it.
And even if we had had a little money, we could get some information out.
You know, give somebody something to say, well, call this number until they're on the situation thing.
It's all right and things like that.
And it was better to appear to be strong than to be weak.
So that's pretty much what I'm saying.
But I didn't understand that I call it now being a modern day, having a hair and a tuff.
But I didn't realize this at the time because I didn't know who hair it was.
And that's a last couple questions.
One is, what was your opinion of folks in SCLC compared to the folks in SNCC?
Did you have a, did you have a SNCC?
Your work was so much better than SNCC.
Did you have an opinion about the SCLC?
SCLC was had its place and so did SNCC and so did CORE,
And so did NAACP.
But the older people, the more mature people wanted not to move so fast.
And the young people wanted to move now.
They didn't want to wait 20 years to come from the back of the bus.
They didn't want to wait 20 years to sit at a lunch cow.
And that's the reason, by me being young, I wanted to be a part of what the young people were doing.
And the difference between SNCC and SCLC was that really SNCC and Corps were like the infantry.
Because we went into places where you couldn't walk the street.
Forget about doing all care with Project, Rector, whatever you're trying to do, it ain't anything to happen.
They were resting us just for being in town.
If you walk the street, you got to rest it.
Anytime they decided to pick us up and the rest of this, what they did.
Vagancy.
And we had to be careful not to get arrested for these kind of things if we could because we needed that funds to borrow out for something else.
But getting arrested for vagueness is okay, everybody have 50% on them or whatever.
You had some money on it.
Which also worked for our advantage.
If we did go to jail, you had 50%.
And you could do something with 50% don't sound like much now.
But you could do much more than you think you could now with it in jail.
So...
Did you have, could you have, make certain friends or have certain allies inside SNCC, that you met as much to you?
Yeah.
Who was that?
Well, one of the persons that I was really...
I could sit in gym, Jim Forman (and is/was) elevator, my mentor.
But people like my friends were especially people that I worked personally with.
And Janet Moses, Ruby Sales, Gwen Patton, Bob Manes.
You could say, Julian, you know, the people that I...
Ruby Doris Smith, Prathia Hall, Sam Block, James Peacock and Willie Peacock.
James is dead now.
They both came to James Peacock, Willie Peacock.
And Sam Block came from Mississippi.
Frank Smith, who has a museum up in Washington, a slavery civil war museum, Charles Sherrod.
All of the people that I knew, Charles Jones, there's a whole lot of people that I knew.
Dottie Zellner, Bob Zellner.
Over a period of time, you know, you get to know people, you see them all the time.
And when you work with them, you get to have a certain bond, constantly, who's one of my best friends?
She came in from California to work.
She worked mostly out of Atlanta office, but Judy Richardson.
Of course, Judy and I went to jail again.
That's another thing a lot of us who went to jail together and spent time in jail together.
I didn't know much about Diane, except for what I heard.
But I'm saying we spend 10 weeks in jail.
You really, really, really, really gonna get to know somebody in 10 weeks.
What is the question?
What was your describe?
I describe her as a strong black female.
Probably, she was much more forceful than some other people.
And by me, I won't be forceful myself and do it.
I'm probably just wanting to see things go ahead.
These are the people that I look kind of looked up to.
And especially the people in Mississippi, because Mississippi was really a hard case going to Mississippi.
Matter of fact, one of the worst things that was one of the most frightening times in my life in the Civil Rights Movement was in the Mississippi and Clarks there.
The night that the clan surrounded our office, they had a curfew on black people.
Couldn't be on the street after 12 midnight.
And 11, 15, 11, 30, you had to be here at home.
The clan surrounded our office one night.
We couldn't leave.
And we didn't want to stay.
And we couldn't see the faces or anything.
The only thing we could see was headlights.
Now we knew there weren't any black people out there doing this.
It was white folks.
They had headlights and they were screaming, it's shouting all kind of representatives.
And this went on all night long.
The only thing we had to guard was under a desk, under a table or something.
Lafayette Surney was the guy who was headed the project there.
After 65, and after the voting, my dad passed it in some of the 65.
What's your role with Step from 65 forward?
Well, we kind of thought everything.
At least I did.
I guess you could say we dropped about.
We thought things were going to get better, things were going to be all right.
Because when I finally went to New York and stayed, I think it was 67.
I was around the New York SNCC office.
It was still SNCC.
It's been SNCC all the time.
Only because SLC didn't put me on stab.
That's one of the only reasons.
There was another thing as they were older and more mature.
And just like I said, a lot of the places that we were in, a lot of places, Dr. King,
just about all the places.
People like SLC, SNCC, corp went, there was already a movement there when we got there.
There was already a movement in a lot of these places.
And NAACP was our legal, mostly our legal.
We had a lawyer once though, Lennox Hinds (low).
I don't know who he is now.
But Len was dating Jaila as much as we did looking to tempt the court with the judges.
We getting Jaila and we standing around and you see, Len, what you're doing here, man?
I bet it here too.
We thought you were outside trying to get us out.
Did you move up to New York in 1967?
And I stayed there for a while.
But then I came back to Atlanta.
And when I had a tax cap service in Atlanta, and I represented Capgrave was there as a organizer.
Capgrave.
And then it's about one thing.
1966, stuck to the comic box, it was the place that John built at the head of Smith.
The rhetoric shifts, there's more move towards the question of oneself defense.
There's more of Black Power rhetoric comes in and folks talk about this.
There's a little bit of a different spirit now.
I think it was radical.
You know, that part became more cultural conscious too.
And a lot of people didn't understand everything that was behind it.
It wasn't just, you know, they heard the word Black Power and they thought about something else.
But that wasn't what it was about.
It was about lifting ourselves up.
And pretty much, I don't know if any organization, any Black organization,
organization that was mixed like that, that went on the violin, Mars, they went on the violin.
Excuse me.
I don't know if any of the black organizations are either integrated organizations.
Never did a violin.
They never did a violin demonstration or go after anybody.
That's violence.
What we did in Hale County was self-defense.
There's a difference between self-defense and overt violence.
And I don't know if any of that, any overt activity.
Mostly it was cultural and trying to defend ourselves.
And younger group of people go do different things.
Some of those folks were younger than us even.
So...
You were on my cultural view of my view.
I was learning about African black people.
Yeah.
I'm just saying and then implying in yourself because if you don't think good of yourself,
nobody's going to think good of you.
And this is when I began to learn more about African American history and African history.
I got arrested in Atlanta for trying to see a big African dignitary.
I finally got to see one here in Selma when he Mandela came here.
I was introduced to her by Rose Sanders.
And I hugged her and I said, I'm so glad to meet you.
I don't know what to do.
You're the first African dignitary that I got to see without getting arrested.
I really want to thank you Miss A.
But you've been so generous of your time.
Well, what I do want to say is that at this time,
I think it was an honor to have been associated with all of the people that I work with.
The SCLC people, the NCAA CPP people, the CORE people,
and now the people who are working with the Bridge Crossing Jubilee and the National Voting Rights Museum and Institute
and the Mississippi Civil Rights Veterans.
I'm just excited and honored to have been associated with all of these people that I have met and known, marrying there.
It's just a whole lot of people we can go on all day.
Well, thank you.
You've given us a fabulous interview and we really appreciate your taking the time and sitting down with us.
Thank you.
Okay. I thank you.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.